ariana grande returns to England for the  first time since the fatal bombing at  her Manchester concert I love spending a  lot of time performing with my fans  ariana was spotted at London's Stansted  Airport on Friday ahead of her one love  Manchester benefit show the pop star  appeared solemn sporting a white  sweatshirt and backpack as she exited  the plane with her parents and boyfriend  Mac Miller the tribute concert will  raise money for the families of the  victims who lost their loved ones in the  attack at least 22 people died and 59  were injured at the May 22nd show fans  will be able to tune in to the live one  hour special as ABC has signed on to air  the benefit concert in the US on Sunday  following the NBA Finals ariana  star-studded lineup includes  performances by Justin Bieber Katy Perry  Pharrell Williams Miley Cyrus and  Coldplay  I think my fans will be really happy  you